it's great to welcome back to the
program today Corey in my focus to say
his last name correctly I almost called
him Carrie Corey doctorow who is a
science fiction author activist
journalist and blogger his latest book
is choke point capitalism how big Tech
and big content captured creative labor
markets and how we'll win them back
particularly interesting now in the
context of all of the concerns around
tools like chat GPT and Ai and the
impact that they may have on Creative
labor markets maybe just to start
somewhere Corey we start there what's
your sense very big disruption coming
from these tools or maybe overblown
you know I I think that um as
interesting as the hypotheticals about
what will happen when these markets
mature and start taking away jobs from
creators yeah uh can be to think about
it's pretty speculative
um there there are elements of what GPT
does that and other ml tools I don't
like calling them artificial
intelligence they're neither artificial
nor intelligence uh but these machine
learning tools
they're also not learning but what they
do what they do uh sometimes amounts to
something that I think is um absolutely
legitimate and the kind of thing we want
to encourage which is thinking really
hard analytically about how art is made
and then making new art that's how I
became a writer uh and you know uh
irrespective of what tool you use to
make your art uh it will always include
some element of Automation and always
include some element of analysis and
making something new by analyzing the
things that came before you it that is
not just legitimate it's how art emerges
and you know one of the things that
we've learned and that choke point
capitalism tries to emphasize is that
when you have an enormous amount of
Market concentration right there's
there's five giant Publishers for giant
Studios three giant labels two Giant ad
tech companies one giant ebook an
audiobook company that that giving
exclusive rights to creators is not a
way to get them paid more it's like
giving bullied kids extra lunch money
you know if you have to do a deal with
one of those companies to go live then
they're just going to take whatever you
got and so you know not long ago there
were a slew of Music lawsuits over kind
of look and feel or groove of songs the
first one was a lawsuit over the song
Blurred Lines that argue that it just
sounded like a Marvin Gaye song yes if
there was any notes from a Marvin Gaye
song Rhythm from Marvin Gaye's song
lyrics from Marvin Gaye's coach you know
uh key changes or or chord progressions
but that it just in its totality sounded
Marvin gayeish and um the victory in
this lawsuit was kind of a uh heralded
in a mixed Way by both by record
industry Executives and by performers
um but ultimately I think you know with
three giant record labels uh if it does
turn out to be the case that there is
such a thing as a groove right and that
becomes well established in law it's
just going to become a feature of the
normal record deal that when you sign a
record deal you sign away your groove
rights and what that means is that whole
genres will become the property of three
companies and there's just going to be
no way to make new art without
submitting to whatever terms they demand
of you that would be the worst case
scenario of creating a new right to
control how people can make new art out
of what they've learned from looking at
your art now there's a much easier case
which is the plagiarism case yeah that's
where that's where machine learning just
coughs up whole sentences paragraphs
images figures from from other art
that's a lot easier that's just
copyright infringement uh in in the main
um but I think that even if they could
guard against that and and as a kind of
pretend computer scientists have an
honorary doctorate in computer science
um I can imagine a pretty easy way to
compare uh output from a machine
Learning System to training data from
the system and ask yourself is is this a
direct lift and if it is then you then
you um uh discard it and start over and
I think that even if that were happening
all of the concerns that people have
about creative labor markets would would
still persist with machine learning
images uh um words and so on if we step
back a little from the creative side and
content creators and talk a little more
generally on the one hand there are more
and more ways in which Computing
generally and by this we might be in
mobile devices Computing generally is
kind of integrated in every aspect of
people's lives jobs shopping travel you
know quite literally every aspect of
people's lives there is a maybe a
growing realization from some about the
power that big Tech has both in terms of
guiding people's choices and in terms of
data in all sorts of different ways
there's a growing realization I don't
know that it's really completely
widespread on and understood in the way
that maybe someone like you would would
hope people would understand what is the
direction of this in terms of what where
this is taking us as a 5 10 or 15 year
timeline yeah you know there's a kind of
Galaxy brain meme version of this right
where you know first you have this
inkling that some computer technology
some digitized element of your life is
adversely affecting you yes right and it
should be better then you realize oh
well this is pervasive across all of
society then you see some muscular
action taken in one corner and you see
it Ripple out across all these other
areas in unexpected ways so for example
um you know the copyright notice and
takedown system that was created in 1998
in the Digital Millennium Copyright Act
really changed the way that we do
copyright enforcement for the digital
era you know when I worked at a
bookstore if you thought a book on the
Shelf infringe your copyright you didn't
just get to march in and say take it
down right right you'd have to like get
an injunction and show evidence and if
it was frivolous you'd face penalties
now under notice and takedown you
literally just send a an email to any of
the intermediaries right so they can be
a payment processor it can be a cloud
provider it can be the ultimate
application provider like YouTube it
might even be an application an
application conduit like the app store
or the Google Play Store and you just
say there's some infringing material
here you need to take it down and by and
large that's what happens that turns out
to have all kinds of weird consequences
right you get cops who play Taylor Swift
songs when people try to video record
them in the hopes that YouTube's
copyright filter will automatically
remove the content yeah you get
reputation management companies that are
really just reputation laundry companies
there's one in Spain it's quite
notorious that works for convicted
torturers murderers human rights abusers
war criminals and it uses fake copyright
notices to make news articles about
their crimes disappear from the internet
you know and so this is the next stage
where you're like oh wait
we need to do this with care and then
you know for me the Galaxy brain stage
the part where you get to the where you
go oh wait there's like a way through
this is to say that
um all of the impediments to making good
evidence-based policy about tech do not
stem from Regulators merely being a
little clueless about technology
Regulators are capable of acquiring a
clue about technology there's no
microbiologist in Congress and yet we
all managed to drink our tap water
without dying of microbial illnesses but
rather that when an industry is very
concentrated you know when the web is
five giant websites filled with
screenshots of text from the other four
it's very hard to have an uncaptured
regulator every time you try to do a
proceeding everybody who shows up from
industry tells the same story even if
that story isn't true and you get kind
of Twisted and distorted regulation that
redounds to the benefit of those firms
and that's why we need to demonopolize
the internet and that's when you realize
oh wait Google is not a company that's
an idea Factory Google is a company that
buys other companies that have good
ideas Google itself has made one and a
half successful products it made a
search engine a Hotmail clone everything
else that's made and bought from someone
else or just copied from someone else
like Chrome which is based on some open
source code uh abandoned by Apple
ironically and and uh you know the the
um uh you know the the products that it
launched internally Google video Google
Plus and so on these all just crashed
and burned it it hasn't made a success
in-house so you know if we were to apply
antitrust laws as they were written
instead of as they've been practiced for
the last 40 years and just so you can't
buy your nascent competitors you can't
merge with major competitors you can't
acquire vertical monopolies you can't
collude with your competitors to rig
markets as Google and Facebook have done
with their Jedi blue program to steal
money from Publishers you know they're
not stealing your copyrights they're
just stealing your money uh that um you
know if we were to apply those laws then
we would have a very different
technology landscape and a lot of these
problems could be much more narrowly
focused we could say to a company that's
doing something wrong hey this is your
conduct remedy here's after you you have
to change your your ways and and clean
up your act rather than creating these
these policies that Ripple out through
uh these individual companies that
control so much of our lives so if we
step back for a second from the
antitrust and sort of regulatory piece
of this at the individual level is this
just like the ship has sailed in terms
of like unless you are quite literally
going to opt out of using devices
leaving any footprint on the Internet
it's just sort of like yeah I don't know
like using a VPN is not really going to
make a big difference here like is is
there anything that individual Behavior
even has as a role to play here so I
think that that in that we need to talk
about Monopoly again to talk about the
role of individuals because one of the
things that made Monopoly possible was
this ideology of consumerism and this
idea that it you that the way that we
make the world a better place is by
shopping carefully that your political
participation amounts to being an
ambulatory wallet uh you aren't going to
shop your way at a monopoly capitalism
but you never were going to shop in a
way that would prevent Monopoly
capitalism you know if you go down the
grocery aisle uh and um you pick up the
product that is a low packaging
alternative because you care about the
environment to some major product it's
going to be made by the same company
that makes the high packaging
alternative it's going to be made by one
of two companies you're gonna love her
or Procter and Gamble the two companies
that make almost everything in the
grocery store
and um if there was a product that was
successful against them if there was
like some local like dude and a leather
apron who is making hipster cookies and
uh everyone was buying them and they
became a runaway success uh either
Procter Gamble or Unilever would buy him
at yeah and they did they'd issue a
process release that said we bought this
company because we know our customers
value choice right well you you can have
any choice you want except for the
choice not to enrich the companies that
are doing bad things which means that
there is no choice for cleaning up
Society to clean up Society you have to
be part of a movement systemic problems
need systemic Solutions the second half
of choke point capitalism is a bunch of
shovel ready solutions that are quite
Technical and have no individual role
except for the role of making these part
of the ideas that are lying around when
crisis strikes because when uh things
that can't go on forever will eventually
stop and when they do there is the space
in which ideas that have been in the air
about how we can make contracts fairer
how we can make business Fair how can we
give individuals performers and workers
more rights that's when they come to the
force so you know for years people have
been talking about what we lost when
unionization went away
um as an individual you can't improve
the conditions of the workers at your
Starbucks but when a hundred Starbucks
moved to unionize because that idea is
in the air because the crisis is struck
then you as an individual have a role to
support the union they'll tell you how
they'll say here's our strike fund
here's the day that we don't want you to
you know we don't want you to buy
Starbucks gift cards this Christmas you
know they they will give you ways that
you can act as an individual as uh to
enhance the the action of a movement but
in the meantime what you can do is is
find out what the systemic problems are
talk about and socialize those systemic
Solutions and then be ready to deploy
them when the moment comes aside or in
addition to the Monopoly and antitrust
issues what else are the big big Tech
concerns to you in terms of you know fun
tunneling people into a uniculture or
whatever right I mean I'll just leave it
open what else should we be concerned
about so you know I wrote another book
uh that also has the word capitalism in
the title it's the season for those
books called how to destroy surveillance
capitalism yes and and it argues with
shoshana zuboff and her book uh in the
age of surveillance capitalism whose
core hypothesis is basically that ad
Tech is a kind of mind control Ray and
that uh while it might have been
invented to sell your your nephew fidget
Spinners it's been hijacked to make your
uncle a q Anon and that's where all of
this collapse and our support for our
institutions comes from it comes from
the persuasive power of AD Tech I don't
think that's true I think that you know
ad tech companies their their greatest
persuasive power is convincing people to
buy ads and that's always been the ad
industry's greatest power but I do think
that people's uh um confidence in our
institutions has collapsed because our
institutions are are not worthy of our
confidence right when the NIH lets
moderna uh um make an mRNA vaccine using
NIH patents without taking a license and
then doesn't step in to assert that
patent when moderna quadruples the cost
right uh and and Scoops up for itself a
four thousand percent margin on this
vaccine that was produced with 10
billion dollars in public money that
that is a reason to doubt the our
institutions and that monopolies pervert
our institutions and so you know to the
extent that ad Tech helps you find
people who are disillusioned it doesn't
not make those people disillusioned and
the way that ad Tech makes people
disillusioned is by abusing our rights
not by being persuasive but by for
example effectively blocking privacy
regulation which we still don't have on
a national basis in the United States I
I think in a world where we our privacy
is so comprehensively invaded so
frequently and so uh visibly when our
Regulators don't step in to give us a
privacy regulation then that that makes
the claims of conspiratorialists who say
that our our agencies are captured
shouldn't be trusted and so on it makes
them credible not because Bill Gates is
putting microchips in our vaccines but
because the agencies themselves haven't
earned our trust so that's I think the
main problem of of big Tech is that big
Tech makes the claims of
conspiratorialists credible which makes
it harder for us to rebuild our
institutions which we really need to do
lastly Corey you know you you are so
well known for issuing these
extraordinarily important critiques of
the system out of sheer curiosity do you
do anything at the individual level that
people might find interesting like you
you stick with an old flip phone just or
you know anything like that
no you know like this is the thing so
I'm not I guess the biggest thing is
that I'm a Zucker vegan I don't have any
Facebook accounts or Facebook adjacent
accounts I'm not on Instagram I'm not on
WhatsApp I'm not on Facebook I'm not on
Facebook Messenger but you know that
doesn't help at least or except at the
very margins because Facebook still has
a dossier on me all right apps on my
phone are built with Facebook sdks which
means that uh they're Gathering data for
Facebook uh and and and Facebook is
maintaining it
um you know I I there are only so many
hours in the day yes I am pursuing
systemic changes right and so if I stop
pursuing systemic changes to pursue
individual ones then I I'm gonna lose
efficacy there's a great bit at the end
of zephyr teachout's wonderful book
break them up about antitrust where she
says if if you spend three hours driving
around looking for a fair trade
mom-and-pop magic markers to make a sign
so that you can go to the strike against
to Amazon and you missed the strike
because you didn't want to buy your
markers from Amazon Amazon wins yes
right and so rather than taking these
meaningless individual steps at the
margins I try to take big step big
swings at the center uh you know that
said like with Arts artistic work
um I I try to buy it in the way that
gives the artist the most money so with
music that means when there's an artist
I love like most recently it was
Penelope Scott I go and buy their whole
catalog on bandcamp which does give
significantly more money to the artist
than listening to them on Spotify okay
interesting yeah I I agree with you
wholeheartedly about the broader broader
philosophy there um the latest book is
choke point capitalism how big Tech and
big content captured creative labor
markets and how we'll win them back
we've been speaking with the book's
author Corey doctorow always great
having you on really appreciate it
likewise it's a it's a great pleasure
nice to see you again David